i'm telling you this movie should write
itself dr balance
he's an aging robotic scientist who
never slips and falls in the shower you
talking about a gremlin with glasses who
could talk and sing new york new york
that's brilliant it's in the movie done
in the next episode steve urkel turns
carl into a giant sandwich and
accidentally eats him what'd i say about
science fiction clyde it's a no all
right
okay guys
gremlins 2.
i'm telling you this movie
should write itself
the first one was a classic this should
be pretty straightforward basically all
we're doing is maintaining the integrity
of the original picture we want to do
all the stuff with the water
and the
uh
can we help you i'm sorry
let me introduce myself hi y'all my name
is star magic jackson jr i'm the
hollywood sql doctor so studio just
brings me in to oversee things when they
about to drop a deuce so that's why i'm
here but don't mind me i'm just gonna be
over here y'all do your thing it's your
movie
okay
uh let's brainstorm
adam uh if it's gonna take place in an
office building i was thinking what if
uh gizmo gets wet from a water cooler
this time okay hold on a second
i'm sorry i'm gonna have to step in here
just one second sweetheart so what's
wrong with y'all
y'all looking like a bunch of sad sacks
this
is g2 people we write in gremlins too it
should be a party with pizza and
anchovies pineapple
just come on lift up the spirits look
okay i'm gonna put a little bit of spice
into the mixture here what if we did
this
everybody here gets to design their own
gremlin
um
i don't see that the uh the gremlin
design is broken it's called
brainstorming i'm brain drizzling sweet
pea okay shut your mouth for a second
look here's the thing none of this is
finals so you mean like what if there
was like a brainy grandma
a brainy gremlin you talking about a
gremlin with glasses who could talk and
sing new york new york that's brilliant
it's in the movie done
whoa whoa you said that nothing was
final that was before i heard the words
brainy and gremlin in the same sentence
together it's done i love it it's in the
movie next
what about a spider gremlin he means a
gremlin with eight legs and a thorax
just catching pretty ladies in a web in
an office building oh my god it's in the
movie i love it
next what about a bat grandma
you mean a gremlin with leathery wings
just flying around flip-flopping bust
through a wall make a perfect bat symbol
in the wall get outside getting some wet
concrete jump up on a building that just
dry in place like a gargoyle wherever we
are cooking with gas now i love it it's
in the movie next
could there be a female gremlin
lipstick boobies [ __ ] you have me in
little gremlin but jj i love it so much
that it's not only in the movie but it's
definitely in the movie there's no
backseats on that one no penny taxis yes
yes yes in the movie done that's why we
need a woman in the writers room next
i don't know
a googly-eyed gremlin
but you do know because you talking
about a gremlin whose sole purpose in
this film it's just that he looks stupid
yes
it can be in the movie and it ends in
the movie done next what about you
silver fox oh electricity gremlin you
just said noun and gremlin like you
playing madness you're just like a child
you have the brain of a child you do not
have a high iq but you have hats and you
came up with a gremlin that's just made
out of bolts that are zigzagging all
over the room and is done completely in
animation you a crazy person and your
ideas in the movie done next uh can we
put the hulkster in it what
[Music]
you talking about putting hulk hogan
professional wrestler
turned actor
turned cultural icon in the movie where
he break the fourth wall of the movie
he's in by talking to the audience you
sir
horror raging psychopath
don't let this town take that away from
you
that's it i don't even care anymore we
got the hulkster in this [ __ ] so it's
done i don't have any more time so let
me just recap right now it's brainy
gremlins spider gremlin back gremlin
lady gremlin googly eyed gremlin
electricity gremlin hulk hogan's gonna
be in the picture i'm gonna throw in a
grandma myself
vegetable gremlin just write it up i'm
having so much fun thank you it's all
gonna be in the actual film now i gotta
go put some cowboys and back to the
future three sayonara y'all
no okay you guys know that none of that
is gonna be in the actual movie
[Music]
so the other thing i'm thinking is maybe
the plasma bolts instead of going the
traditional way and having them actually
emanating from his hands what if they
came from his aura and just came uh he's
here oh god thank you guys
this is so exciting
marvel legend stan lee calls me on the
phone a couple of weeks ago and says
i'd like to stop by so i just thought
that'd be a great treat so he's
excelsior hey
mr lee all right all right sit down sit
down let's get going oh you're here to
pitch us some characters you bet your
bottom dollar i have
all right let's see here you gotta
the easel works a little bit rusty don't
touch that
okay
introducing
heyday
he lives perpetually in his best year
1982.
his nemesis is the evil writer's block
he'll live forever as long as he
continues to come up with great
interesting and relevant ideas
well that got nothing mr lee i just i
just feel you're really busy this
morning
this ain't my first rodeo sonny boy i
got a million of them all right
dr balance
he's an aging robotic scientist who
never slips and falls in the shower
it's where am i man no matter how late
at night he gets up to go number one he
always knows exactly where he is
thermostat
he has the power to control any
thermostat which means he never has to
be tormented by any sudden
cold spots techno he understands how to
control any technological device things
like the computer or the little hand
computer
road rage
he gets behind innocent drivers on the
thoroughfare on their way home from the
doctor's office and he leans on his
radioactive horn and they say hey
come on get off of my bumper hot rod
we're going as fast as we can
where'd you guys come from
oh yeah here's the gray chaser
her special powers are she's 40 has no
kids and she's got a rocking hot bod
she's only into older dudes with
ponytails and liver spots holmes dead
he's got the mutant ability to force any
of his busy adult children to come visit
for a change i mean would it kill you to
pick up a phone how about an evil
villain huh the overweight jamaican man
also known as jamila
she steals things
mr lee i'm i'm so sorry just with all
due respect i don't think that uh
i don't think that we could use any of
these
characters
oh
so say the room
[Music]
yes yeah
oh
oh i i understand don't mind me uh
sometimes you're just
shooting blanks
i know when i'm not wanted just
toss the rest of them in the trash
compactor or whatever you got these it
was a real honor sir to have you yeah
eureka
i've just been inspired
now this is a superhero team
a ragtag group of multi-ethnics
known as
the fired bunch
they possess the testicular fortitude to
bite the very hand that feeds them and
are cursed to walk the streets
for an eternity unemployed
what do you think
we love it
[Music]
this
is
what's the matter rich in the next
episode steve urkel turns carl into a
giant sandwich and accidentally eats him
oh wait that's hilarious but it's
hilarious come on i'm an actor gene this
was supposed to be about me and my
family i know but you know after that
after that first death spot with steve
urkel i mean america fell in love with
him man we had to make him a regular and
you know hey listen he's the star of the
show now sweetheart we gotta play ball
bubba don't you dare bubble up me gene
now last week steve used his
transformation machine to turn carl into
a car and drive him around the monaco
grand prix come on how many times are
you going to use this transformation
machine this was supposed to be a blue
collar cosby show now you turn it into
goddamn quantum leap who writes
i i couldn't tell you even if i wanted
to okay maybe we got like 21 writers up
there okay you know what i'm saying
reginald but you and i both know that
they don't decide what happens in the
show okay we both know who decides what
happens in the show two weeks ago steve
urkel used his invisibility ray on carl
and i wasn't even in the goddamn episode
it was just my voice yes i know i know
rachel i'm sorry i apologize will never
happen again then steve used his voice
changing ray to turn carl into a
high-pitched nerdy voice who do you
think provided the voice for that don't
get too feisty on me now reg let's not
go down that path okay oh oh we're going
down that path gene in a couple of weeks
harriet eddie laura grandma aunt rachel
little richie and the other little kid
are gonna get teleported to another
dimension and then steve injects carl
with his own dna so carl turns into
another steve urkel that's two steve
urkels and no family on a show called
family matters how the does that work
listen listen ranch i don't want to tell
you urkel mania is unstoppable okay he's
a phenomenon there's nothing we can do
about okay it's up to
him no no no no no i'm an actor i'm a
factor i am a real actor i need richard
the third i was in true west with
sherman helmsley i was in die hard damn
it
steve urkel
you will suck steve urkels if he wants
you to you will suck this do you
understand he has our bread and butter
you mother
i am high on cocaine i'm a
gene i've done more cocaine than you
weigh mother i'm gonna tell you what you
are wrestling phil johnson you're a
pawn in that nerd's game
you are a
pawn do you think i have any power over
what that monster does any power at all
i am the senior
vice president of development for the
american bro
gene
gene
gene what's become of eugene
i
am nothing
do you not i don't know what you mean by
that team but you're scaring me no no
don't don't do anything crazy gene
everyone does too much coke sometimes
but just what are you gonna do with the
gun gene what are you gonna do no no no
no no no
we can talk this through
uh okay
the king is dead
live the king
did i do that
[Music]
jaleel jaleel
there is no jalil
only steve
it's always been steve
give me guys
forgetting something carl
don't you come near me stay away from me
here could have all been so simple
carl
just say your lines
and take the money your monster
what are you doing
i i i can't control
am i doing this
no no no no no no no no see i'll do
anything you will do what i want on
family matters
yes oh
of course steve
[Music]
see you on set carl
get out of my house steve
call my agent
jaden pickett smith my man what up clyde
hey look man i'm gonna be real with you
okay this alien boy script i'm not
feeling it i mean it's hard being will
smith's son i just want to make sure my
next project reflects that i'm a
down-to-earth normal kid am i making any
sense yeah yeah i'm reading you loud
clear i've got a script right here very
real called street ball talk to me okay
so you play tony he's a kid from the
streets lives in the hood in a house
with his mom stop
[Music]
house
oh it's like a
tiny mansion got it go on so his mom and
he uh they live in this house and she
works at a supermarket ah
oh uh a supermarket's like a mansion uh
but it's full of food and anyone can go
there so like where the butlers go
yeah basically so so he uh and wait
you said his mom was doing something at
the supermarket working so
working is kind of like acting on a set
every day in a film that no one's ever
gonna see and it lasts for the rest of
your life oh like a maid
yeah yeah she's like the maid of the
supermarket awesome continue so anyway
tony doesn't make the basketball team
right so he decides to start playing
pickup games of street ball outside so
he plays basketball on his plane
on the ground
in his limo no uh outside is that stuff
that goes by when you're inside the limo
oh snap he plays basketball outside the
limo door
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so then he gets
really good at basketball and then blah
blah blah blah fast forward at the heart
of the story tony has to choose between
his mom
yeah choose is when you have to make a
decision between two things you want but
you can have only one
but
there's two
yeah but i mean
he can't have both
what'd i say about science fiction clyde
it's a no
okay we'll pass
dad bless you thanks
[Music]